so the first month of the new year
usually means big business for the
fitness industry people across the
country are looking back at our previous
year reflecting on the collective hours
and days spent lying around like slugs
consuming three times as many calories
as we burn off on a good day our
waistlines expanding to blimp-like
proportions feeling the fleeting pains
of guilt for all of this remembering
that both sloth and gluttony are deadly
sins and thus
resolving to finally begin engaging in
some form of physical movement in the
year ahead of course the problem is that
once we embark on our new health and
wellness quest we discover that exercise
is you know difficult
and uh worst of all it takes up time
that could be better spent watching tick
tock videos and so the resolve dies away
and the gyms empty out as quickly as
they were filled though most of the
people who abandoned their gym routines
still continue paying their membership
fees hoping that at least
being a dues paying member of a gym
might you know count for something as if
heart disease will see their membership
card on their keychain and pass them
over on that basis alone
the fitness industry
does not need you to actually get
healthy and fit it just needs you to see
health and fitness as at least
theoretically desirable
but what happens when these things
health and fitness and general physical
wellness
can no longer be presented as even
theoretically desirable that's when you
end up with absurdities like the latest
issue of self magazine
now self is an online publication
allegedly focused on health and beauty
and owned by the same mega corporation
that gives us vogue the new yorker gq
vanity fair wired
pretty much every other magazine in
existence it would seem
self's first issue of 2022
looks so on the nose
so perfectly representative of all of
the foibles of wokeness that you might
at first think it's some kind of
intentional self-parody
and it is self-parody but it's just not
intentional as you can see on the cover
here
um it features an obese woman in spandex
along with the headline
the future of fitness
and one wonders if the next issue will
have a picture of a square with the
headline the future of circles or the
number five with the headline the future
of two plus two
in any case the subheadings on the cover
promise to give us more information
about quote the relentless reality of
anti-fatness in fitness and quote four
ways to respond to unnecessary
encouragement at the gym
yeah you know all those bullies at the
gym that uh encourage you
an introductory article by the
editor-in-chief lita shy
explains the point and purpose of this
health magazine's new focus on promoting
obesity she writes quote in this digital
issues articles and essays when we say
future we're not talking about the
latest fitness trackers or streaming
workout equipment we're talking about
the people who are changing the
landscape of an industry that has for
too long excluded many over the past few
years thanks to the body positivity
movement as well as other thoughtful
explorations that have challenged
complacent ideas about weight and size
we've seen an important shift in how we
discuss larger bodies
but fitness spaces can be a final
frontier in a particular strain of body
discrimination where anti-fat bias and
weight related stigma are entrenched in
our collective understanding of what it
means to be fit it's time to break free
from this limited view the future of
fitness is about making space for
everyone to feel welcome
so in this package we're celebrating the
people who are helping get us there
now clicking through to discover the
whole package we find articles with
titles like quote 12 pieces of running
gear that can make running in larger
bodies more comfortable
now i know what can make running in
larger bodies more comfortable
a salad but i'm guessing that doesn't
make it on the list other titles here's
how to find a gym that's size friendly
and quote these 10 people are
challenging how the fitness industry
treats fatness and then how to feel
competent at the gym when you're
starting out according to 12 larger
bodied exercisers
now please note the updated pc lingo
here um a fat guy at the gym is no
longer a fat guy at the gym he is now a
larger bodied exerciser
if all of this doesn't sound inane
enough
then how about this headline
six things fitness instructors should do
to become a better fat ally
and quote seven seemingly empowering
body positive phrases that actually
reinforce ableism
and then my favorite
seven ways to repair your relationship
with movement
now i love that last one because it
provides a very useful framework for
laziness which of course is what is what
all of this is really doing but now when
my wife asks me for a third time to get
off the couch and go take the garbage
cans out i can just say sorry honey i'm
really working on my relationship with
movement right now
we've decided to take some time apart
and it's for the best can you bring me
another beer by the way i need you to be
a fat ally honey
now it's easy enough to laugh at all
this because it's so interminably stupid
but unfortunately this stuff doesn't
just live on tumblr tumblr blogs and
weird internet forums anymore this is a
health magazine
published by one of the largest media
companies on the planet
imagine if men's health
put out an issue on alcoholism but every
article just encouraged you to keep
drinking as much booze as you want
six things you can do to be a better
binge drinker ally
here's how to find an aaa meeting that's
byob
these 10 drunk drivers are challenging
how the court system treats impaired
driving
for now anyway though this could change
as we continue our slide down the
slippery slope everyone would agree that
such content would be not only
ridiculous but harmful evil even
as it would actively encourage people to
destroy themselves it's like finding a
suicidal man standing at the edge of the
roof
and shouting you should totally jump if
you want to don't let anyone judge you
if you jump maybe you can fly only one
way to find out
and this is why of course fat acceptance
will never be anything but morally
perverse and repulsive
it's like bulimia acceptance or the
acceptance of people who cut their
wrists
to love someone is to will their good
that is to help them towards
um
towards
what is good for them but if you're
helping them towards degradation despair
and destruction that's hatred
or at least indifference
this is also why obesity is not an
identity
it's the erasure of identity
both because it will kill you
i mean literally erasing you physically
from existence
and also because it covers
the defining parts of you
it will always be absurd to claim that a
morbidly obese woman is physically
beautiful
she's not
because her feminine features are
covered in lard i mean you may as well
say someone is most beautiful when they
have a blanket over their heads
beautiful in this context context is a
description of physical features but
morbid obesity overtakes all of your
physical features covers and destroys
them so that when you call a morbidly
obese person physically beautiful
you must be describing the obesity
itself as beautiful
which is to say that destruction and
sickness are beautiful
which is itself a sick thing to say
this is the backwards world we find
ourselves in when self-perception reigns
perceive
supreme it's a problem we talk about
often on this show because it lies at
the root of almost everything that's
going wrong in our culture
in a world where the ego is king
the job of everyone around you is to
reinforce how you perceive yourself or
how you at least want to perceive
yourself
because you shouldn't have to conform
yourself to any outside reality there's
no truth greater than your truth your
will your ego
so if you want to feel healthy and
beautiful as everybody does
then society must simply declare
that you are both of those things
it would be an act of unthinkable
oppression
for anyone to tell you that though you
want to be those things you're not
even if they lay out a plan and they
promise to help you become what you want
to be
if they say you're not those things
right now
but you can be
here's how to do it i'll help you even
that is oppressive
because it implies that there's a truth
and reality greater than the individual
ego
something that the individual must
navigate through
rules that he has to follow
and the modern narcissist simply cannot
accept that
so he stares in the mirror
tells himself fairy tales about himself
and everybody plays along
cheering him on
and on and on and on
and all the way over the ledge
hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated